Мусимо виживати. Нема, де подітися.
Анна Василівна живе у Бородянці. Її гуртожиток російські військові
обстріляли з танка ще у березні під час тимчасової окупації.
Будинок в аварійному стані. Пошкоджені дах, стіни та комунікації.
Ще світло зробили і це все. А так обігрівач вмикаю, щоб зігрітися хоч трохи.
І все. Газу немає. Води немає. Ходимо, просимо по людях воду.
У кімнаті стоїть старенький обігрівач. Він - її єдина надія не замерзнути взимку.
Обігрівач гріє. А що зробити? Не сидіти ж у холоді.
Ще двері такі, що одні щілини. Закриваю ковдрою, щоб не дуло.
Бо ми як прийшли сюди, то вони взагалі лежали посеред хати.
Так, як навісили - так і сидимо.
Та якщо відключать світло - пенсіонерка просто не зможе вижити в морози.
Одягатися будемо, кутатися - та так і будемо сидіти. А що робити?
Росія продовжує обстрілювати українські міста - щоб залишити людей
без газу та електрики. 10 жовтня ракетами пошкодили 11 важливих об’єктів
критичної інфраструктури у восьми регіонах України та в Києві.
Через це у частині областей були перебої зі струмом, зв’язком та водопостачанням.
Загалом унаслідок російської агресії уражено понад пів тисячі котелень,
теплоелектростанцій і теплових пунктів.
Є запаси вугілля на сьогодні. Так, їх поки що недостатньо.
Орієнтовну цифру називало міненергетики близько двох мільйонів тонн вугілля.
Якщо вважати на весь опалювальний сезон - цього не вистачить нам.
У зв’язку з тим, що в нас захоплені Запорізька АЕС, декілька ТЕС
або захоплено, або зруйновано, ТЕЦи в Охтирці, в Кременчуці, в Чернігові
зруйновані, тому в нас намічається деякий дефіцит електроенергії
в опалювальний сезон. І тому ми сьогодні спалюємо вугілля.
Ситуація з газом також складна, каже експерт. Але держава і місцева влада
продовжує підготовку до опалювального сезону, у тому числі й на випадок
влучання ракет у теплокомуненерго - закуповує генератори, мобільні котельні,
готує програму забезпечення дровами територіальних громад.
Готуються й українці. Перевіряють електрощитові у будинках,
утеплюють вікна та купують обігрівачі.
Щоб нам хоч не дуло з балкону, то ми отак вже позаклеювали собі.
Воно наче не дує. Обігрівач у нас є. Якщо буде світло і буде все нормально,
напруга, то мерзнути ми не будемо взимку. Але ж ми не знаємо,
чи буде ще все добре зі світлом. Не буде світла - тоді я не знаю.
Може підемо у приватний будинок до сестри.
Якщо у багатоквартирному будинку не буде газу і тепла - догрітися
можна електрообігрівачем. Від літа попит на них зріс у понад 50 разів.
Лідерами категорії, знову ж таки, є теплові панелі, конвектори
та масляні обігрівачі. Кожен із цих приладів може обігріти, стати основним джерелом
опалення як невеликої кімнати, до 5-ти квадратних метрів,
так і обігріти велику площу - до 35 квадратних метрів.
Масляні обігрівачі будуть довше нагріватися, але й довше віддавати тепло.
А конвекторні та керамічні нагріють швидко, але так само швидко й охолонуть.
Тому обирати треба індивідуально. Так само можна купити звичайну настільну електроплиту,
щоб готувати їжу і гріти воду. Але треба пам’ятати,
що усі ці прилади можуть перевантажити електромережу.
Потужність, яка в середньому надається на одну квартиру,
маючи на увазі в старих будинках, в більшості старих будинків,
це всього 2,5 кіловат. 2,5 кіловат - це холодильник, телевізор,
увімкнене освітлення в квартирі і нехай це буде комп’ютер.
І більше ви нічого не зможете підключити. Кожен сусід ваш на поверсі,
в під’їзді повинен розуміти, що якщо всі одночасно увімкнуть опалювальні прибори,
такі як масляні радіатори, вітродуйки і все інше, то погорить у вас і проводка,
погорять щитові, ви спричините пожежі, це може призвести до летальних наслідків.
Тому всі електричні прилади потрібно розводити по кімнатах і не вмикати одночасно.
В ідеалі домовтеся із сусідами про графік вмикання електроприладів.
Вистачить поділитися на парні і непарні квартири.
У приватному будинку все простіше. Якщо перебито газогін, можна палити дровами.
І купити генератор або піч-буржуйку.
А от у квартирі можна використовувати портативні кемпінгові пічки
і газові пальники з балонами, щоб зігрітися і приготувати їжу.
У нагоді стануть свічки, ліхтарі та батарейки. Обов’язково треба мати
заряджений павербанк чи акумулятор. І запастися теплим одягом і термобілизною.
Та якщо у багатоквартирному будинку взимку не працюватиме електрика,
тепло і каналізація - тоді з нього треба буде евакуюватися.
Будинок не життєдіяльний і в цьому випадку люди не зможуть
в ньому знаходитися, тому що не будуть працювати насоси,
не буде працювати вся система і фактично потрібно зливати воду
із системи теплопостачання і переїжджати.
Це найперше радять зробити жителям зруйнованих деокупованих міст,
в яких не встигнуть відремонтувати всі комунікації до зими.